présentement c'est plein ici dans notre
sur l'île temps nous dans nos salles de
répétition et l'on n'a rien il n'y aura
pas de touristes cet été sur l'île ou
puce l'île de la mythique sagouine
c'est comme un non sens ça jamais arrivé
dans l'histoire du pays de la sagouine
si rien ne change la traction restera
fermée en raison de l'interdiction des
grands rassemblements
mais ce n'est pas la seule raison les
touristes seront interdits d'entrée sur
le territoire et les premiers ministres
ne vois pas comment ça pourrait changer
au cours de l'été à ce jour le
nouveau-brunswick ne compte plus que
deux personnes atteintes de lakovic 19
au point de vue qu'avec c'est peut-être
désastreux ce niveau là côté santé
publique spécialistes mais j'ai comme
l'impression qu'il faut faire éditions
le moment donné c'est vraiment l'eau ou
avoir transformé la céréale le maître
distillateur sébastien roy vient
d'investir plus d'un million de dollars
dans une nouvelle malterie
mais le virus a fait chuter ses ventes
de spiritueux et sa boutique il reste
désespérément vide
il comptait sur cette saison pour
renflouer ses coffres en partie mais ce
ne sera pas possible du québec c'est je
vous dirais c'est promis 65% de tous nos
touristes
c'est même catastrophique
quant au repas ces revenus là en un plan
pour essayer de survivre
les prochains 24 mois il n'est pas le
seul à souffrir de la fermeture des
frontières
c'est l'argent qui sort au camping le
colibri le téléphone ne dérougit pas ce
ne sont pas des réservations mais bien d
annulation du québec nous ce qui nous
importe présentement c'est d'avoir ou le
plan hockey si c'est pour ouvrir dans un
mois on peut planifier humer le
gouvernement dit le ministre n'a
toujours aucun échéancier pour la
réouverture des frontières et encore
moins de plan pour soutenir
financièrement les entreprises
touristiques
pourtant l'île du prince édouard annoncé
une aide spécifique de 66 millions de
dollars à ce secteur
il y à un mois et demi terre-neuve en a
fait autant lundi avec un programme d'
aide de 25 millions de dollars
c'est sûr et certain qu'il va falloir
ouvrir un moment donné on peut pas
toujours rester enfermés ou dans notre
enclos parce que sinon survivre pour
attaquer en industrie touristique
ça va être lancée d'ici trois semaines
pour sauver les meubles la péninsule
acadienne mise sur le tourisme local
avec une nouvelle campagne marketing
mais le nouveau-brunswick ne compte que
sept cent cinquante mille habitants
environ la population de la ville de
québec et ce ne sera pas suffisant
non
définitivement pas les touristes
québécois paul nous la péninsule
acadienne c'est énorme
sébastien roy se tourner aussi vers les
gens de sa région de distillateurs il
s'est improvisé producteur d'
antiseptique pour les mains et c'est
pour le marché très laquelle il ya des
gens des restaurants qui commence à
ouvrir les églises qui commence à ouvrir
viennent chercher de lentilles c'est est
présentement c'est 60% des ventes c'est
d'antiseptiques qu'on ait main ça nous a
sauvés que
financièrement d'une catastrophe tête
croisée un autre interprète la mairie si
pour terminer leur expérience au pays de
la sagouine un théâtre de fortune sera
aménagé pour répondre aux nouvelles
normes sanitaires y faire travailler les
interprètes autant que possible c'est
souvent on disait toujours seul comme on
le pauliste et parce que c'est dans ma
cour arrière
le celta le pays ces 150 comédiens pour
l'heure c'est eux que luc leblanc essaie
de sauver le plus possible